the first time ever a black woman will
take the diamond as a professional
baseball
coach 29 year old bianca smith will join
the boston red sox this upcoming season
as a minor league coach it comes just
over
60 years after the red sox became the
final major league team to integrate
think about that
cbs this morning saturday co-host dana
jacobson spoke with smith about her
historic hire
in an interview you're seeing first on
cbs this morning dana good morning to
you tell me everything
good morning there's a lot to tell tony
bianca smith's love of the game dates
back to when she was just a little girl
her mother introduced her to it
and some of her earliest memories are
watching the world series with her
father despite that passion
she obviously never saw anyone who
looked like her on the field
now all she has to do is look in the
mirror
if people think you know it's just
because i'm a woman well
then i'll just go out and prove them
wrong proving people wrong
may as well be bianca smith's
catchphrase her path into one of sport's
most exclusive clubs
was paved with anything but gold
i love the idea that you know yes
representation matters but then there's
also the idea that
just because you don't see it doesn't
mean you can't do it because somebody
has to be the first
otherwise it's never going to happen
smith grew up playing soccer before
turning to softball in high school
she was fast and talented but an injury
during her senior year
seemingly ended her chances of playing
in college at dartmouth
i picked cheerleading instead so i
decided to cheer and started working for
the dartmouth baseball team and i ran
into the softball coach
going to visit the baseball coach and
she just asked hey do you want to try
out for the team then
i wasn't gonna say no so i tried out and
made it and uh
wow it's like fate was directing you
there
yeah it was crazy i never expected that
to happen
smith's love of the game developed as
she starred on the dartmouth softball
team
and the club baseball team she'd go on
to earn a dual business law degree
in sports law and sports management at
case western university
all while working as the team's director
of baseball operations
she had dreams of joining a major league
baseball front office
baseball internships in the
commissioner's office and with two major
league clubs were next
but she realized her passion wasn't in
the office
it was on the field itself coaching
there are times where i definitely felt
like i wanted to give up
like that period between the
commissioner's office and the reds
i actually worked eight jobs at one time
one of them being a volunteer coach
just so i could pay for an apartment why
didn't you give up
my parents uh surprisingly there were
times where they even said why don't you
just go ahead and take the bar
go practice law for a bit but they saw
how much i wanted to do this they saw
the drive and the passion how much i
loved coaching
and they were willing to do whatever was
necessary to help me
that support was all she needed for the
past two years
smith served as an assistant coach and
hitting coordinator
at carroll university in wisconsin their
team moniker
none other than the pioneers the
headlines are saying
first black female coach in major league
baseball
for you what is this about it means more
now
um than it did before and that's this is
not what i was thinking when i accepted
the offer
uh when i accepted i was just thinking i
get to coach
um i knew it was going to be a pretty
big deal
this actually ended up being i didn't
realize how big this was to people
but to me this is just an opportunity to
hopefully inspire other
other women other women of color who are
interested in this game
who might even have the idea that they
want to coach but because they've never
seen somebody looks like them doing it
it never really occurred to them that
they could do it too
smith told me that her gender has
actually been more of a challenge
in baseball than her race but added that
she can't differentiate between the two
because as soon as someone sees her they
obviously
see both as for women in baseball she's
joining a handful of coaches the first
hired just last year
and she told me she looks forward to the
day when hirings like theirs don't make
headlines
gail they are just the norm wow oh i
love everything about her in this story
thank you dana
i mean think about that guys eight jobs
two degrees
you go bianca dual business law degree
that is
that's impressive i love that her
parents when she was in a moment where
she wasn't sure what she was
going to do said no stick with this yes
yes you know what i'm adventure
advice yeah i'm going to send her a ring
light today because something tells me
she's going to be doing a lot of
interviews
and it was hard not being able to see
her whole face i want to see your whole
face bianca because you look fantastic